if you've probably all heard this thing
called zum-zum conferencing it's how I
do my interviews it's how a lot of late
night hosts talked to celebrities these
days and a lot of businesses you zoom so
anyway here was my idea what if I
crashed a real corporate zoom meeting
for a small business so you know just to
get their morale up try and get that the
economy moving again
so we found a company we found an
insider at a company called TIBCO in
Palo Alto it's a real company they
didn't know I was going to show up
I found the information on how to log in
and so I don't know where I crashed a
TIBCO meeting strategy meeting to try
and liven things up did that earlier and
well check out what happened good
morning I was still in Hawaii there he
is I asked Dan to join us today and he
was gracious enough to do it I did
thanks a lot partner for joining us I'm
loving absolutely mark look God doing my
best to join as many of these you know
our local team calls as possible
we don't know exactly how long we will
be right in this challenging moment we
do know there will be a recovery we
don't know exactly what that looks like
but preparing now like Mark said on
things like our strategic account action
plans that support our customers goals
are the things that we'll be able to be
ready for as we move out of that so I
just wanted to make sure I came on to
reinforce that we're in a great place to
be able to support and work about
communities I want to apologize I'm late
for the meeting I'm new to the company I
wanted to break in mostly because it's
pretty clear that Dan has lost his way
with TIBCO I mean if you have to put the
name of your company on a bar behind you
things are getting sad Brian here I just
want to say I'm disappointed I'm
disappointing it in our sales
performance I'm disappointed in a lot of
you across the board this could be a
great company if we get off our asses
and make it a great seems to be the
problem
oh and Alan's got his fun back
you were busy calling up a fun
background first guy on Zoom to think of
that you could have been thinking of
real solutions to get ahead of our
competitors this is a real opportunity
for us to take TIBCO into a new
direction have ideas I do would you like
to hear them yes sir bring it I think we
should offer a more streamlined process
for partner onboarding who's with me
anybody yes by exposing api's that
reduce the need for custom coding making
it easier for them to integrate with
their environment can we do that yeah
well are we excited about Apache Kafka
yeah oh my god when they put the chip in
your brain they sunk it in deep didn't
they what happened to you Dan remember
remember when you were a roadie in a
band and you had dreams Dan you look
great for the company early on when you
were hungry but now you're so busy
putting the TIBCO name on furniture you
forgot what it is we do I want to
customize information exchanges by using
api's over the web in place of
proprietary EDI networks these are great
ideas keep them coming
keep them coming but Adam is busy
reloading his bong what are you doing
you're in Canada right now yeah you have
a slightly different work ethic and no
health insurance in this country but you
got it you've got to focus now guys no
one's together on this can we just pull
together as a team Alan Becky
Damon Adam Molly Terry everybody can we
pull together and Mark what are you
doing
looking for something big oh that's good
I think we're having a series of small
heart attacks didn't know what this was
worried about you guys I cannot pull
this company together by myself your
suggestions for me as to how I can help
this company I really want to do my part
anybody that you're a great morale
booster so far really do you think the
attention you've gained anything from
having me at the company since my son
did it six minutes ago guys tip toe is a
dream to me and I think it could be your
dream too can I at least get a TIBCO
sweatshirt out of this I know we all
know you have like 50 in the trunk of
your car all right I'm gonna go bomb
about 30 more businesses today god bless
all of you you're doing the Lord's work
and the Lord's work is TIBCO are you
with me go tiptoe one two three well
that helped no one
my thanks to TIBCO they are a real
company and a fine company I thank them
for their indulgence and we're gonna
take a little break when we come back
Bob Odenkirk is gonna be joining me and
if you feel like you're in a giving mood
and you want to do a little something to
help we're recommending now that you
donate to Partners in Health coronavirus
emergency response